>> Greg: I LOVE THIS.
I AM DOING A SHOW HERE.
HE WOULDN'T GIVE UP THE SPORT SO
SHE SAID "SEE YOU IN COURT."
GISELE SAID TAKE A HIKE TO THE
GUY WHO USUALLY TAKES A HIKE.
PAGE SIX, THE NUMBER ONE NEWS
SOURCE BETWEEN PAGES FIVE AND
SEVEN HAS A PART OF THE IS
HEADED FOR DIVORCE.
PEOPLE HAVE EXPRESSED FEELINGS
OF SADNESS, DISBELIEF AND
NAUSEA.
WHAT MEDICAL EXPERTS CALL THE
KILMEADE EFFECT.
I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON SOMETHING
MORE IMPORTANT, THIS.
>> WHO'S FAULT IS IT?
I WANT TO KNOW!
>> Greg: TIME TO POINT SOME
FINGERS.
INSIDE SOURCES HAVE THE COUPLE
HAVE BEEN LIVING SEPARATELY FOR
MONTHS THAT THE FINAL STRAW WAS
BRADY AGREEING TO PLAY ANOTHER
SEASON OF FOOTBALL.
GISELE HAS SAID SHE'S GIVEN UP
HER OWN CAREER, WHATEVER THAT
IS, TO FOCUS ON SUPPORTING TOM
AND RAISING THEIR FAMILY.
SHE'S EXCITED FOR HIM TO RETIRE
SO SHE CAN FOCUS ON HER
LONG-TERM GOAL, GETTING BACK
TOGETHER WITH LEO DiCAPRIO.
SOME OF THE SOURCES SAID THAT
THE ISSUES IN THEIR MARRIAGE GO
BEYOND BRADY'S DECISION TO PLAY
FOOTBALL WHICH I ASSUME INCLUDE
ARGUMENTS ABOUT WHO IS PRETTIER.
IT'S TRUE.
WHEN THEY ARE SEEN TOGETHER,
THEY RARELY SEEM TO BE JOVIAL,
LIKE THIS PICTURE HERE.
WHOSE SIDE ARE YOU ON?
>> Brett: I AM ON GISELE'S
SIDE.
>> Greg: BECAUSE YOU'RE
SITTING NEXT TO THE JUDGE?
>> Brett: SHE LEFT THE RUNWAY
IN 2015, LEFT EVERYTHING BEHIND
TO BE WITH HER FAMILY.
HE TRICKLED PROBABLY WANT THE
SAME THING FROM HIM AND HE SAID
NO.
IT'S TOUGH TO GIVE UP SOMETHING
THE LOVE AND SHE'S PROBABLY
ASKING HIM TO DO THAT.
A FEW MORE YEARS LEFT HE CAN
GIVE.
I'M IN HER COURT ON THIS ONE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE MAKING A PLAY
FOR HER, DISGUSTING.
>> Brett: I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE
BRADY ON THE SINGLES SCENE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE BEING A WING
MAN.
HIM JUST ROLLING IN SINGLE AND
READY TO MINGLE?
>> Greg: HIM AND I WENT TO THE
SAME HIGH SCHOOL.
I'M SURE HE'S GOING TO NEED A
WING MAN.
I'LL BE BUSY BECAUSE I'M HAPPILY
MARRIED, AS YOU KNOW.
YES.
>> Judge Jeanine: YES.
>> Greg: WE HAVE A HEATED
CONVERSATION EARLIER, YOU ARE ON
THE SIDE OF GISELE.
YOU CLAIMED SHE MIGHT HAVE A
CAREER.
>> Judge Jeanine: SHE
ABSOLUTELY GAVE UP HER CAREER.
SHE WAS A SUPERSTAR MODEL.
>> Greg: YOU SAID SHE WAS
SUFFERING.
>> Judge Jeanine: SHE WAS
LIVING THROUGH HIS FOOTBALL
CAREER.
THAT MEANS HE GETS UP AT 5:30 IN
THE MORNING, GOES TO BED AT 8:30
AT NIGHT, HAS THESE CRAZY DIET
REQUIREMENTS, SHE'S WITH THE
KIDS ALL DAY LONG WHILE HE'S
PRACTICING.
>> Greg: THAT IS CALLED BEING
A WIFE.
A SEXIST WOULD SAY.
SEXIST WOULD SAY.
>> Judge Jeanine: HELPING TO
RAISE HIS CHILD WITH ANOTHER
WOMAN.
>> Greg: HE IS A LESBIAN?
>> Judge Jeanine: SHE IS WORTH
MORE THAN HE IS.
HE SAID HE WAS RETIRING HE TOOK
IT BACK.
>> Kat: THAT'S THE WORST PART.
SHE'S MAD AT HIM BECAUSE GOING
TO KEEP PLAY FOOTBALL.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
HE SAID I'M GOING TO RETIRE TO
SPEND TIME WITH MY FAMILY.
THEN HE SPENT TWO MONTHS WITH
HIS FAMILY AND WAS LIKE
"EEWICH."
I WOULD BE SO OFFENDED.
I'M NOT EVEN THAT HOT.
SHE HAS NO HUSBAND FROM AUGUST
TO FEBRUARY.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
FOOTBALL SEASON IS TOO LONG FOR
ME.
I GET UPSET ABOUT HOW LONG IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE WANT TO
WATCH IT AND I DON'T WANT TO
WATCH IT.
I IMAGINE IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
IN GETTING THE -- INCONVENIENT.
IT SHOULD BE A LESSON TO WOMEN
TO NEVER MOVE TO TAMPA FOR A
MAN.
>> Greg: TYRUS, I'M GOING TO
AGREE WITH WHATEVER YOU SAY.
>> Tyus: YEAH.
POOR GISELE.
MOPPING FLOORS AND RAISING THE
CHILDREN BY HERSELF.
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T HAVE A STAFF
OF NANNIES, PERSONAL ASSISTANT
COME AT A PRIVATE JET TO FLY TO
ALL THE GAMES AND PRACTICES AND
MEET EVERY RICH PERSON ON THE
PLANET, SHUT UP.
SHUT UP.
YOU WERE A MODEL.
YOU HAVE MONEY AND YOU GOT TO BE
WITH AMERICA'S FAVORITE SON,
TOM BRADY.
THE MAN IS INSANE.
HE ALREADY HAS A WING MAN.
HIS NAME IS GRONKOWSKI.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: ALL SHE HAD
TO DO?
>> Tyus: THIS IS MY TIME.
GO BACK AND PLAY FOOTBALL TWO
MORE YEARS HE WOULD TRAVEL THE
WORLD.
IT WAS HER IDEA TO GO TO TAMPA.
SHE'S THE ONE WHO GOT INVOLVED
AND MADE BILL BELICHICK BLOW OFF
SHE WAS YOKO
ONO >> HE'S 45 YEARS OLD!
>> Tyus: EVERY RIGHT TO KEEP
PLAYING.
>> Kat: MOST PEOPLE WANT MORE
FOR THEMSELVES THAT A PARTNER
THEY NEVER [BLEEP]
C.
>> Tyus: SHE'S RICH.
SHOULD BE FINE.
>> Kat: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE DIDN'T
GIVE HER A CHOICE.
>> Greg: THE UNSPEAKABLE
TRUTH, ONLY RICH PEOPLE CAN GET
DIVORCE.
POOR PEOPLE ARE STUCK WITH EACH
OTHER.
NOBODY EVER TALKS ABOUT THAT.
>> Tyus: THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
LIVING TOGETHER IN A YEAR.
IT >> Greg: IT'S A BUSINESS
TRANSACTION.
MEANWHILE POOR PEOPLE ARE STUCK
WITH EACH OTHER BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE OPT